How do you describe a Magic: the Gathering deck?
Experienced players have a rich lexicon to draw
upon while talking to each other about decks—this
deck I’m playing is a red-white aggro deck,
it’s a burn deck in boros colors, a sligh
variant existing within the Lorehold color
identity if you wanna get real creative with your
terminology. Certainly, players can have different
interpretations of these terms, and arguments
about semantics do pop up from time to time,
but ultimately as players we’re more on the
same page than we think. Where things get
tricky is when it comes time to talk to newer
players, or even people with little to no MTG
experience to speak of. How do you describe
midrange to somebody who is unfamiliar with
the concept? It’s doable but it can be a little
tricky, and overloading somebody with too many
abstract pieces of terminology isn’t the best
way to build up a practical understanding of
the game. This is where simple archetypes end
up being very useful. A lot of players start
out by building around mechanics or keywords—my
first deck was a mono-black bloodthirst deck,
which I played against my brother’s mana ramp
deck and my cousin’s spellslinger deck. And,
by far the most approachable of
these types of decks is tribal decks.
When I tell somebody I’m playing a zombies deck
or a dragons deck, most novice magic players will
understand roughly what sort of deck I’m talking
about, and there will even be plenty of people
who don’t play the game who can follow along.
It helps that tribes usually match mechanically
with broad cultural understandings—zombies are
a horde focused around death, dragons are big
flying beasts that shoot fire, knights are
warriors who prefer fair and direct combat,
ninjas are skilled at getting in and out of places
sneakily, slivers are—okay it’s not perfect but
it’s pretty good. I’d even say that tribal decks
perform an especially important function in EDH.
Limited events and 60 card kitchen table magic
are probably better ways to learn the game,
but for better or worse EDH has become a big
place of onboarding for newer players within
the landscape of paper magic, and tribal decks
are one of the best options for learning the
game within that context. While lots of
EDH decks have high levels of complexity,
with the structural elements that hold a deck
together somewhat obscured to an untrained eye,
tribal decks leave large portions of their
synergies bare and on the table. To check if
a card synergizes with Hakbal of the Surging
Soul, I don’t need to look at anything but
the type box on a card—if it’s a Merfolk, it’s
worth consideration. These decks are also usually
straightforward to play compared to non-tribal
decks—simply play cards of that tribal type,
interspersed with lords to maximize the value from
those cards, a category which usually includes
the commander. A simpler gameplan means less to
think about on a player’s own side of the table,
and offers more time and mental space for a
newer player to strategize, pay attention to
cards their opponents are playing, and get
a better feeling for the format as a whole.
So yeah, I’m a fan of tribal decks on the whole,
particularly in the way they offer a smooth and
satisfying experience for newer players. I
also don’t say any of this to insult more
experienced players who like tribal decks—I’ve
built a number of tribal decks over the years,
and my current strongest deck is a tribal
deck. However, I think a lot of tribal decks
end up falling into some lazy deckbuilding
patterns, even when they’re constructed by
players with a decent amount of experience
under their belt. Just as having a core
creature type can be a helpful hand to hold
for newer players, it can be a real limiting
factor if a player is unable to break out of
that mold. On the surface Zombies, Goblins,
and Dragons all sound like valid gameplans,
but are they actual plans for playing the game?
Let’s take a step back for a moment. I’m going to
make two statements, the first of which I expect
to be fairly uncontroversial, and the second
of which might be a bit more challenging to
people. Statement one: not all tribal cards are
good in every tribal deck. Kargan Dragonrider,
though it is more powerful in a dragon deck than a
non-dragon deck, still probably isn’t a card that
most dragon players want. Statement two: not all
tribal cards that are good on paper are good in
every tribal deck. For a couple examples of this,
I’m going to reference the EDHRec page of Miirym,
one of the most popular tribal commanders.
One card that jumps out is Crucible of Fire,
played in 22% of decks. On paper,
this card is amazing. The going rate
for a basic anthem is 3 mana, maybe 2 mana if
you’re restricting the creatures it affects,
and by that metric this card is giving 6 mana
worth of anthem for 4 mana—that’s great! Lots
of tribal decks would happily accept that kind of
efficiency, and a good number of green black elf
decks are happy to run a card that is far worse on
an objective level. So what’s the problem? Well,
anthems are an awkward choice in a dragon deck
because it’s not a go-wide deck. Realistically
you’re going to have a low single digits number of
dragons a large portion of the time. There aren’t
that many low cost dragons nor many cards that
produce dragon tokens outside of Miirym, so if
you have a big enough board to make an anthem
good you were probably already headed either
toward victory or toward a board wipe. An even
more questionable choice is Acolyte of Bahamut,
played in 34% of Miirym decks. This enchantment
provides ramp at a decent rate, and it’s a great
fit in a Korlessa deck, where the commander
is two mana and has a somewhat modest effect
that won’t attract too much removal. However, if
you’ve ever played with Miirym you know that if
the Miirym player is allowed to untap with her in
play, an avalanche of bad things will frequently
follow for the other players at the table. And
your opponents need to allow you to untap twice
with your terrifying 6 mana commander before
Acolyte, a ramp card, has become mana-positive.
To me, this card is a clear instance of one
of the more pernicious side effects of tribal
deckbuilding. Just as it’s helpful for newer
players to be able to rapidly analyze cards
based on having and mentioning a card type, as
players gain experience this sort of instinct
often gets encoded as a heuristic to follow if
they aren’t actively pushing back against it.
If a card does theoretically helpful things
on a theoretically high enough power level,
players’ brains are often tuned to shortcut a lot
of the details, details that really matter. On the
surface, if I’m a Miirym player looking at Acolyte
of Bahamut, it’s doing all the things I want—it’s
nice for my expensive dragons to be cheaper,
and I really like my commander so most games
I’ll have it in play anyway. It’s only when we
deconstruct what Miirym does as a commander, what
a dragon deck is actually trying to do, and what a
Miirym dragon deck’s strengths and weaknesses are
that the card’s issues start to become obvious.
And when that sort of analysis doesn’t happen,
thousands of players end up keeping a
really mediocre win-more card in their deck.
Okay, so I’ve laid out some tribal deckbuilding
habits that I find to be problematic and which
lead to decks that function worse. With that in
mind, how does one make a tribal deck that feels
cohesive and effective? Fundamentally,
it comes down to developing an identity
and a gameplan for your deck that’s more
complex than “play insert creature type
here”. That can be a difficult process,
but a good way to start tackling that task
is looking at your core tribal cards and asking
yourself “what is this offering me? What sort of
gameplan might play well with these cards?” I’ve
built a number of tribal decks over the years,
and I’m going to reference some of the more
successful ones as examples for this. One such
example is my high power pirates deck—I picked
out a command zone with a couple pseudo-lords,
started with a calculated number of low-cost
pirates to utilize their effect, and then added
additional pirates and pirate-tribal elements
on an individual basis where I thought it was
worthwhile to my general gameplan to do so. A
large part of the deck’s gameplan features the
tribe and tribal creature beatdown is a genuine
wincon, but there are also a number of layers
of the deck that diverge from the nature of a
pure tribal deck, mainly cards centered around
tribal payoffs such as the treasures that Malcolm
generates. To me, this deck checks all the boxes
of what good tribal deckbuilding should look
like, but this deck is decidedly on a higher
power level than most tribal decks, so I’ll
also mention a couple lower-power examples.
One of the decks in the $25 deck pool I’ve talked
about was an Arahbo cats deck—don’t talk to me,
the card was like a dollar when I built the
deck in 2020. The deck isn’t that weird from
a composition standpoint—it’s running a few
of the affordable cat lords and a moderate
overall creature count of 27—but it nonetheless
is built with a more specific mindset than just
“play cats”. The commander’s eminence gives
a single cat +3/+3 until end of turn on each
of your combat phases, and already this diverges
from the conventional tribal deck mold—rather than
rewarding a critical mass of cats, this commander
rewards having a single cat early in the game to
get maximum use out of the eminence ability. The
commander’s on board effect is an amplification of
this—it rewards having a small quantity of large
cats, since each cat buffed requires spending
3 mana. For this reason, the deck’s creatures
are lower-cost than ones in a lot of cat decks,
and it runs a lower creature count than average
in order to have a healthy suite of equipments
and a number of draw spells which check the
power of a creature on board. In this way,
the deck dips into aggro and voltron themes in
addition to being a midrange-y tribal deck, and
this extra attention paid to being cohesive with
the tribal core allowed the deck to end up feeling
a lot more focused and threatening than most
budget tribal decks. As a final example, sometimes
I’ll stumble accidentally into a tribe. When I
built a rogue tribal deck for the $25 deck pool,
I didn’t actually start with the idea of it being
a tribal deck. Rather, I built out the core of the
deck with a focus on evasive creatures, curiosity
effects, and a high density of interaction,
and then went “wow I have a lot of rogues in this
deck” when I stopped to look at what I’d built so
far. From there, I added the rogue-tribal cards
which made sense with the original gameplan, which
was actually a fair number since the tribe as a
whole is heavily based around evasive creatures.
Basically, what I’m trying to convey here is just
that a key step in developing a tribal deck is
building an identity for it outside of the tribe
alone, and finding that identity will work best
when it focuses around the core pillars of the
deck’s gameplan. Now, I do get the sense there
may be a lot of you that are feeling pretty safe
right now, shielded from what I’m saying in this
video by the fact that you don’t play tribal
decks. It’s at this point that I feel this need
to tell you that most of these points also apply
to any deck based around a specific mechanic or
a set of words such as “enter the battlefield” or
“cast from exile”. If you make a deck by throwing
together a big pile of stuff focused around that
mechanic without considering a broader gameplan,
your deck is probably going to feel like an
unfocused mess for purposes of closing out the
game. I talked about this more in my wincons
video, but basically when a player chases
a particular mechanic or tribe rather than
chasing a gameplan for their deck to follow,
they often end up with a pile of different payoff
effects that all contribute toward different
goals. In addition, lots of potentially
helpful cards may be left by the wayside,
with that deckspace instead occupied by filler
that doesn’t really contribute meaningfully to
what the deck’s synergistic elements are actually
accomplishing. This kinda sucks on some level,
because this game has something like 30,000
cards and finding the right cards for a deck
out of all of those would be a much easier process
if it could start and end with a single gatherer
search. And honestly, I think that vastness of
cards alone is a valid reason to use a tribe,
a mechanic, or a few words as a starting
point to build upon. Just keep in mind
that it is a starting point at the end of the
day, and if that’s the point you’re at you’d
be well-served to focus on what’s at the heart of
your deck and figure out how to better serve that.
Thanks for watching! I’m currently taking
submissions for my Patron deck review this month,
so if you have an extra $3 a month
to throw at me and want a chance
to have me review your deck, a link
to my Patreon is in the description.